the White House is pushing back against
a report that a lawyer for president
Trump suggested pardoning former Trump
campaign manager Paul Mann aport and
fired National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn the New York Times says John Dowd
who left the president's legal team last
week floated the idea to attorneys for
the two men they both face charges in
the Russia investigation Paula Reid is
at the White House with new questions
over the Trump teams response to the
robert muller probe paulo good morning
good morning
the president's former attorney denies
pardons were ever discussed and
yesterday the White House said pardons
are not currently on the table but
sources close to the case tell CBS News
that manna fort does not intend to
cooperate with Special Counsel robert
muller and that he is banking on a
presidential pardon if he's convicted a
metaphor currently faces nearly two
dozen felony counts and his first of two
trials will begin in July for bank fraud
meanwhile Michael Flynn has pleaded
guilty to lying to the FBI about his
contacts with Russia's ambassador and he
is cooperating with Special Counsel now
Flynn is the critical link tying contact
with Russia to the Trump campaign and as
part of his plea deal he admits that he
called Russian officials during the
transition at the direction of senior
transition officials Flynn could still
potentially get a pardon but that's a
lot less likely if he provides special
counsel with evidence against the
president's inner circle Anthony Paula
thanks